la ministra de defensa española detalló
que el país este mismo viernes enviará
material bélico a ucrania en concreto
más de 1300 lanzagranadas 700 mil
cartuchos de ametralladora y
ametralladoras ligeras el anuncio llegó
algunas horas después de que el mismo
presidente pedro sánchez revelara en el
congreso de los diputados y para
sorpresa de muchos este cambio de
posición ya que el ejecutivo había
repetido en varias ocasiones que se
limitaría a colaborar con fondos
económicos a la entrega de material que
ya va a hacer la unión europea a través
del fondo europeo de apoyo a la paz el
cambio de opinión viene dado según la
ministra de defensa española por la
rápida evolución de los hechos en
ucrania que ameritan una respuesta
acorde para que los ucranianos puedan
defenderse
este envío era algo que desde la
embajada ucraniana en españa' se llevaba
pidiendo desde que se produjeron los
primeros ataques hace una semana sin
embargo la decisión no ha sentado muy
bien a algunos de los socios del
gobierno de coalición que defienden que
el acuerdo era que españa sólo enviara
material humanitario para algunos de los
integrantes de unidas podemos el envío
de más material bélico solo ayudará a
escalar el conflicto